[Music]
alright see the clock on the bottom
right of your screen that's how much
time's left for the Senate to strike a
deal to avert a government shutdown down
to the wire less than seven hours the
House passed a short-term extension
yesterday but Senate Democrats are
insisting the legislation include
protections for young undocumented
immigrants this afternoon President
Trump invited Minority Leader Schumer to
the White House to negotiate an
agreement no deal but a little progress
as usual in Washington plenty of blame
going around on both sides I wish for
all of our sakes that the Democratic
leader would figure out what he actually
wants the best that the Republican
leader in the Senate can offer us is
another band-aid another four weeks of
temporary funding a wasteful gesture a
wasteful exercise and he knows it so
what they're simply trying to do is hold
all of government hostage our troops
kids health insurance for a completely
unrelated issue and I think it's
shameful Democrats have consistently
been ready and willing to sit down at
the negotiating table and reach an
agreement with our Republican colleagues
but we will not be blackmailed alright
so the Republicans Jesse I'll go to you
first very disciplined on their message
said we passed a clean CR there's
nothing in there that you don't agree
with why not just go ahead and do that
and we'll keep talking to you about the
other stuff I'm just bored by the whole
thing
I think this country is run by imbeciles
we're twenty trillion dollars in debt we
do this every single year we spend more
and more money on this government and it
does less the only thing that works in
this government and the military I know
and something that sometimes you shut it
down and then nothing happens and you
think do we really need it but the
Democrats think they have leverage here
because the polls are obviously going to
turn against the Republicans but it
looks like to be there putting dreamers
over the
the military is not gonna get paid
firefighters aren't going to get paid
postman aren't going to get paid but I
don't think Congress should be paid
because this is ridiculous the American
people going to wake up on Saturday if
they shut this out and say okay so how
does this affect me every year we get
involved with this silly drama these
politicians pull us into their silly
drama and everybody with the countdown
clock it's ridiculous only happens with
these guys one right before I came down
I saw there are Republicans saying that
every Democrat senator who's running for
reelection in a red state and there are
many of them that they should have ads
run against them this weekend that says
you are choosing illegal immigrants over
800,000 children who would be funded
with children's health insurance program
effective no there's just so much so
easy to counter-attack because obviously
you could have passed the chip program
the children's health and probe health
insurance plans at any point the
Republicans didn't do it and so now you
have a situation where you have
Republican in the White House Republican
House Republican Senate they have not
been able to reach a deal they can't
pass a budget so we come back to them
the argument about the dreamers and and
you hear and Jesse just reacted to this
he said oh it's about the military or
it's about something else
guess what it's all about President
Trump causing chaos and people don't
know how to deal with that people don't
know exactly well even Republicans don't
know exactly what it is that Donald
Trump is willing to sign here they
thought they had a deal wanna sign the
budget one well if that's the case then
Republicans have the wirele
filibustering in the Senate nobody's
filibuster you know they're not usually
vote 60 votes one that's right six
that's not a filibuster Jesse 60 vote
let me just say it's everybody hated for
in the house oh please let me the chip
me in the bill but not the dreamers
we've been
it's not a spending iterators have
nothing to do with the budget but let me
just say Oh American support I think
it's close to 80% of Americans support
the dreamers Donald Trump the president
he opened the negotiations Gregg he said
he was willing to make a deal that's not
that's not part of that it's not part of
the spending thing and you keep saying
oh they have the house and they have the
Senate we know you need 60 votes so
let's kill that argument yeah problem I
will I will say this when they were if
you want to know who to blame when the
Democrats are in power when this happens
it's the Republicans and when the
Republicans are in power it's the
Republicans so if you if you notice a
trend here it's the Republicans fault
but I will say this about the
Republicans the Interior Department at
least said you don't need staffing if
there's gonna be a shot down you could
still have the open-air memorials and
you could have the national parks open
in case of a shutdown you don't need
staffing so unlike Obama they didn't
like to use barricades to score
emotional political points which makes
me think maybe Republicans are better
people
Kimberly earlier today secretary mattis
over at the Defense Department did the
end of the National Defense review
basically and it was very stark and then
this is what he had to say about the
shutdown thanks it's got a huge morale
impact I'll just tell you how long can
you keep good people around when
something like this happens it is always
a question it's got to hover in the back
of my mind yeah I would just tell you
that we do a lot of intelligence
operations around the world they and
they cost money those obviously would
stop cagey yeah like you know the last
thing you want to do I mean honestly as
Jesse mentioned a couple things I'm like
a chair VRS let me tell you however the
military I chair for and when you see a
situation like this and you hear someone
speak about it like general mattis I
think the last thing you want to do is
jeopardize our national security and
affect the morale there it's like the
one thing we've been getting
consistently perfect attendance and like
an a on is your United States you know
military and it just seems like it's
just such political gamesmanship and you
know what the American people can see
through it and it's frustrating because
they should put through
spending well there's no need to go
through these kind of machinations
whatsoever but nevertheless they persist
yeah and our enemies Greg this is what
mattis was talking about earlier China
Russia in particular are fully funded
they can plan well ahead they have
everything that they need and we are
superior but we've got to stay on top of
things yeah I mean it goes back to the
initial point that this the Democrats
were willing to shut down a government
over a political cause mm-hmm there
think they will they will stop funding
things are important to citizens in the
United States over a political cause
they're willing actually to throw over
one one group of minorities for another
group of minorities if it serves them
politically I do I have to say there is
one there's a little bit of progress
here and that is calling it the Schumer
shut down it's like it's like it's a
smart move because alliteration trumps
everything if you remember the left
tried to what do they cut we're calling
donald trump donald drumpf with dr
didn't work now yeah because abstract
cleverness that repeats alliteration
Kratz had better hash tags in the tax
reform debate yeah no Republicans but
yes Schumer shut down was good but then
I was gonna ask you Jesse Senator
Schumer was invited by President Trump
up to the White House they neither of
them have revealed what was said in the
meeting
the only thing Schumer said is that
there was progress what do you think
they talked about they might have cooked
up something where Trump comes in and
saves the day or Schumer comes in and
saves a day we'll see what happens but
Schumer and Pelosi there are doing right
now the exact thing they accused
Republicans of doing in 2013 which was
being arsonists and hostage takers and
shutting down the government for
something totally unrelated to the
ultimately in the long run that the
shutdown helped them so Juan do you
think that the Democrats are thinking
that this is a possibility for them too
well I think that people are looking
right now Dana and saying why does the
government this is at the top of what
jesse was saying why does the government
always get in a situation even mark
short the legislative director for the
White House said this is a function this
is a dysfunctional Congress and he's
talking about that so people are saying
well you mean Republicans and Democrats
well obviously no it would be great if
we could get back to regular
budgeting for everyone it would yeah but
I just can't take what you gotta say oh
yeah yeah you know why why is this being
brought in remember this
this whole issue of dacha so popular
with the American people was forced by
Donald Trump he created this crisis when
he shut it down this F because I want a
deal and we're going to set up margin to
be found
everybody illegal let's not do the spin
let's just look at that truth the facts
are that this deal has been expanded
there were two continuing resolutions
done in December on the premise that
will make a deal in January the
president this banger to the budget you
keep spinning just the truth it's not
spin so here's what has President has
the bipartisan deal this is Monday a
week ago and everybody comes again says
here we think we've got it come back mr.
president they come back to him with a
deal a bipartisan deal Republicans and
Democrats roll that's when he was there
is no text of a bill about dreamers to
vote on
there's no vote on something right now
friends when they came back to the White
House when they came back to the present
you shouldn't call it the Schumer what
Dan we should call it the lawn shop no
we should say that not alliterative your
way of dealing with things is to shout
and streams you're very much like Trump
is for Schumer Trump is the one that
Republicans can't even trust he's the
one who says oh yeah
don't put chip in the deal don't do that
we want to clean the deal doesn't matter
it's in the record saying we don't have
any reliable leadership or direction
coming from this way all right a little
point of history yeah yes my first day
on the job on Capitol Hill as a press
secretary was the first day of the first
government shutdown in 1995 always shut
down whoa we should have another clock
this clock right here for the next shut
down like just move ahead
just having as it's [ __ ] it's gonna
happen this bucket stupid [ __ ] yeah it
could be even next week if they get this
er done
alright US history made today